all right so we've had some clouds since
yesterday we've had them overnight and
now we're looking off to the east and
the clouds are kind of sliding away from
us so kiddos really this morning is
about the last you'll see of most of
those 60 degrees is a good average as
you're off to school and then 77 this
afternoon we should have good sunshine
but we're gonna have some breezy
northwest winds today too maybe up to
about 25 miles an hour so things are
going to be blowing around now bianca
talked about dust and pollens and then
you stir it all up with the wind and
that does make allergy sufferers a
little more miserable today so take
those antihistamines we have mulberry
ash and elm all blooming with high
counts right now a lot of low 60s and
some upper 50s around the valley boulder
city you're in those low 60s perump in
the 50s this morning so breezy winds
today and again with another system over
the weekend temperatures will be up and
down we still have that roller coaster
going of temperatures spring officially
begins sunday morning with our first
chance of spring showers too coming
along with it so we're looking at the
west coast the jet stream kind of
pointed at us here and it is bringing in
another system that's pushing through
the intermountain west that's what we're
seeing now and then another one on the
weekend that will drop in from further
north and that will have some cooler air
with it this one's not really cooling us
down today but tomorrow we will drop a
few degrees you'll see it in the eight
day forecast so clouds through the
intermountain west even some light snow
and rain showers mostly up in utah
northern arizona we've had some radar
returns in the moapa valley but i don't
think any of that's even touching the
ground it's mostly cloud cover and you
can see the clouds are clearing from the
west so we should have some really good
sunshine here pretty quickly north winds
to 25 miles an hour as i mentioned so
pretty bumpy highs in the upper 70s
today we dropped to low 70s back to near
80 for our last day of winter but cloudy
skies and then a chance of rain even
saturday night into sunday morning
spring arrives a little after 8 30 in
the morning and we'll drop to 67 for a
high showers lasting until mid afternoon
then we get sunny skies next week and
we're all the way up maybe to low 80s